un homme qui se libèrent jean marie
villemin a parlé aujourd'hui devant les
assises de dijon
en principe la journée était consacrée à
l'audition de personnalité mais tout a
été modifié lorsque l'accusé du procès a
raconté son drame
son histoire sa vie dominique verdeilhan
bruno girodon l'homme qui s'exprime
devant la cour est avant tout un père
celui de grégory meurtri inconsolable sa
voix se brise s'étrangle jean marie
villemin debout ferme les yeux comme
pour mieux dérouler le film de son drame
dans une atmosphère pesante la salle
revit elle aussi la sphère 16 octobre 84
grégory dit au revoir à son père c'est
la dernière image que j'ai de lui dans
le rétroviseur
jean marie villemin sanglote s'accroche
au montant de la vitre pare balles
puis c'est l'insoutenable image un corps
sous une couverture
il était beau il ne paraissait pas mort
celui qui a fait ça je veux la voir
avant la justice est il promis ce soir
là la mise en liberté de la roche
ce fut un choc c'est comme si on tuait
une deuxième fois mon enfant face au
président 800 qui brandit l'armé du
crime jean marie villemin raconte les
quatre tentatives qui ont précédé
l'assassinât
je voulais également enlevé muriel et
marie-ange marie-ange c'est quelque
chose je le sais je le sens
la roche m'a dit c'est pas moi j'ai tiré
au jugé ensuite je me suis précipité à
la clinique retrouver christine je ne
voulais pas qu'elle l'apprenne par les
radios
bernard laroche coupable jean marie
villemin n'a aucun doute
aujourd'hui encore il assume sa
responsabilité même s'il reconnaît avoir
été conditionné par la presse d'abord
dont il dit elle nous a fait autant de
mal que les gendarmes par l'incompétence
d'un magistrat par les policiers aussi
qui ont porté leurs soupçons sur
christine jean marie villemin n'a eu
aujourd'hui qu'un seul souci faire
oublier l'accusé pour ne se présenter
quand vie de tir